welp Donald Trump met with Russian
President Vladimir Putin and I know some
people don't like it when I say this but
he was totally cocked like the beta male
that he is and we're usually joking when
we say that Pat right I mean we're
parodying this outright insult of saying
people people are kuck and blah blah
blah but the term kind of does apply I
mean Donald Trump was reduced to the
child in the room and I know it's crude
but he was totally betta in his cucking
a by Vladimir Putin if there was ever an
appropriate time to use that word it
might be right now let's go to the video
where Donald Trump looking like the shy
reduce child in the room who takes
direction from the big boys here's
Donald Trump talking about just what
what an honor it's been to be with
Vladimir Putin what was enough people
well thank you very much in Greece
Travis President Putin and I have been
discussing various things going very
well that's a very very good call I'm
gonna have a talk now and obviously that
will continue but we look forward to a
lot of very positive things happening
for Russia for the United States and
tell everybody concerned and it's an
honor to be with you
yeah I think you were watching no
handshake games no nonsense from Trump
Trump can't handle Putin and Molly
McHugh an information warfare expert who
we've interviewed previously did a great
article in Politico which says it's it's
not just the visuals here that are
embarrassing for Trump as the total beta
in the room
she points out that Trump failed
miserably at the g20 and also in this
meeting with Putin specifically by
talking about working with Putin by
basically talking about friendship with
Russia Trump is falling prey to
everything Putin has done overtly and
covertly over the last two years to
force this realignment that Putin wants
right we've been saying this for a long
time
Trump has allowed Putin to push Russia
into being a bigger player without
having to account for their misdeeds
right the Ukrainian invasion election
hacking oppression of press and LGBT
individuals and political dissidents and
there's a readout of what took place in
the meeting between Trump and Putin and
it's just laughable I mean Trump is the
epitome of weakness here the United
States is going to move on from election
hacking issues with no accountability or
Consequences for Russia
Trump actually floated the idea of
working with Russia on cybersecurity do
you realize the absurdity of this it's
like the Fox kills a bunch of hens in
the henhouse and then the lead hen comes
out and says we're going to be looking
forward in our relationship with the
Foxes rather than backwards and we're
actually going to be joining the Foxes
in working together on henhouse
protection initiatives what what and the
blowback was so bad too that Pat that
Trump has already sort of started to
back off and say well it's a great idea
but it's not really something that we're
going to do because it's just so absurd
it went from a good idea to a bad idea
in the course of a day and you even had
Marco Rubio saying that this was akin to
creating an anti chemical weapons
Commission with Bashar al-assad yeah
Ariya Lindsey Graham says you know I
like Trump's policy on North Korea on
Isis but when it comes to Russia it's
just dumb
it doesn't make any sense also in this
meeting according to the readout which
has been made public Putin and Trump
agreed not to meddle in each other's
domestic affairs I wonder who that
favors the most and they also announced
a sort of limited ceasefire in Syria
which is going to serve as a basis for
cooperation between the US and Russia
and here's the stunning part of this
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said
that the Russian approach to Syria might
be quote more right than that of the
United States do you know what the
Russian approach in Syria has been it's
been one that has led to mass civilian
casualties endless displacement of
people wholesale destruction and borders
that have just been erased this is a
catastrophe right the guy who ran on
strength and being tough and the rule of
law blah blah blah has gone to the
leader of the country identified as our
biggest adversary by the 2012 Republican
nominee something which at the time most
Republicans agreed with and is basically
ceded every aspect of what Vladimir
Putin was looking for Putin is playing
trumped like a violin and this is why
Putin wanted Trump elected it worked
look at the deference that the Russian
President has gained from the American
president in an instant he got
everything he wanted he's getting the
compounds back in New York and Maryland
or wherever it was the bombing of the
Syria runway you might say but David no
Trump clearly is going against Russia
doing what he wants because he bombed
that runway in Syria that runway was
back up and running within hours we
warned Russia ahead of time and our
Secretary of State says you know
Russia's approach might actually be more
correct on Syria than ours they hacked
the election Trump believes they did it
sort of sometimes depending on when you
ask him but they decide to agree to
forget the past and they're going to
move on if Barack Obama did this if
Hillary Clinton did this Republicans
would be calling for their heads in
violent apoplexy this is bordering on
treason it is historic the president of
the US think about this pat the
president of the US helped into office
by a foreign government and he's a
ethically sang-su to the American people
to the voters Hooton now gets everything
that he wants it does sound as if Putin
went into this meeting knowing exactly
what he wanted and got every single
point and Trump gave up every bit of
leverage that he kept because he could
have had by accepting Putin's account
every way under mining the US
intelligence community and by not even
mentioning the fact that Congress is
working on a bill to up the sanctions on
Russia and the worst part of it is since
Republicans in the House and Senate
won't do anything about it
and since Republican voters just don't
seem to care there's not a damn thing
anybody's going to do about this